[Music]
colossal quick and dangerous
this monstrous vehicle part ship part
airplane
is on a beach by the caspian sea in the
republic of dagestan
the ecranoplan or screen glider was
designed for military use
presumably against the west
alligato abdugulimov served as flight
engineer on test flights for the wing
ship
or ground effect vehicle as they're
generically known colloquially this one
is called the caspian sea monster
i operated the propulsion units from
here
it's a great machine just incredible
the first wing ship was designed in the
1960s
it was meant to guard russia's
coastlines and fight enemy ships
while staying undetected by radar thanks
to its low flight
this uses the ground effect aerodynamic
interaction with the surface beneath
the wings create just enough lift to
carry the 380 ton giant a few meters
above the water
[Music]
but it never saw genuine service
fourteen years after the caspian sea
monster's launch
the soviet union collapsed and test
flights were ended
we were so proud of our country at the
time for developing such
let's call them products unlike what any
other country in the world
because it didn't need long runways or
airports
devoted 14 years of his life to the
ecrano plan
he logged a bit more than 500 hours of
flight time
which he says is not much for a
professional test pilot but the flights
were anything but easy
something always went wrong the
prototype had only been built for test
flights
we had various firefighting protocols in
the event of an accident
today the caspian sea monster stands
near their bend
a two-hour drive from abdul kalimov's
home
the now retired flight engineer is proud
to have been the only dagestani on the
team of soviet researchers
hardly any photos remain from his time
with them
after all it was a top-secret soviet
military project
when the head of our test pilots
division found
[Music]
today party membership means nothing the
country alagaji abdugulimov was so proud
of
the soviet union is history and the
colossal wing ship is destined to serve
as an attraction
in patriot park a tourist site planned
on the caspian sea coast
at least it's still standing here
there was talk about dismantling it
i hope it will help young people
understand what fantastic technology we
had
and what a great country
and so the caspian sea monster faces a
very different mission in today's russia
to bear witness to the one-time power
and greatness
of the former soviet union
you